the word on Twilight was like you took
it so seriously when you got that part
but you almost got kicked off that set
because you were being a pain in the ass
about the character right I mean you got
onset and you made a lot of not demands
but a lot of thoughts about how the
character should be I mean I just
thought you know considering now now
that's why it's known to be this a very
emo thing I mean there was a period I
was just you know I thought it's very
very serious kind of thought at the time
it's like 21 and you haven't if you're
going into a relationship with someone
the way to make it really intense is if
like you can barely talk to each other
you can barely touch each other it's
incredibly serious all the time I'm it's
kind of like what teenage relationships
are like and that's what sort of makes
us feel like that but everyone kind of
wanted it to go no they should be like
happy and having fun that's what people
want and that's kind of you know that's
that's the sort of teen romance thing
you wanted it brooding a little bit yeah
now that the whole series is known as
the kibou didn't think that but yeah
they're kind of I remember that produce
has given me a copy of the book and like
every single instance with my character
smiled and stuff highlighted everything
so you put your foot down you said hey
listen man I don't see the character
that way I'm not going to said man I got
the same but I got a different color
highlighter and highlight it all how
many frowns and Caillat did your agents
put pressure on you and stuff to say hey
you better just get with the program or
they're gonna fire you oh yeah
they came they flew up and said like you
could have because I thought I was
pretty safe right there and they flew up
and they're like yeah you gotta you have
to do the opposite of what you're doing
now you're gonna get fired today so how
did you hold your ground I mean how did
you know what to do I didn't I look for
came back I came back up to lunch with a
car
I'm smiling vampire I wanna keep my job
oh my god you can't even do what you
want
mm so what I did I mean is that you just
off at that point instead of I mean I
was probably going a little bit too
miserable and so I owe some kind of
compromise my